Why do startups fail? Well, the answer is really all of the above.
Co-founders do fight.
Somewhere between a quarter and third of startups
never even get to the beginning of the company because the founders just couldn't agree.
Two is that sometimes your vision is just too far in advance to actually be built.
The three is it's such an interesting vision or such a bad vision,
but it can't attract sufficient capital to get started
and it's maybe too expensive to fund on your own through your own resources.
And the one we'll be actually talking about in some detail during the series of lectures
is that you never actually found product market fit and there's too few people
who will buy or will use the product.